Speaker 1: All right, let's look at some
humorous and funny moments from CPAC 2023.
These are some of my favorite moments from a
comedic standpoint. Some of you may remember
that 2024 Republican presidential candidate Nikki
Haley suggested a competency or cognitive test
for any politician age 75 or older. Now, she
overtly met this for Joe Biden, but part of
her campaign against Trump has been that she's
younger and she's from the next generation. And
so we know that when she talks about cognitive
tests for those 75 and over, she also means and
it would apply to Donald Trump. Well, the CPAC
crowd is very MAGA friendly and they weren't
going for it. And when Nikki Haley suggests the
cognitive tests, the mental competency tests,
the crowd is silent. You could hear a pin drop
in there, not a Nikki Nikki Haley friendly crowd.
And I absolutely love it. Look at this.
Speaker 2: When I launched my campaign,
I said every politician over
75 years old should be required
to take a mental competency
test. Have you seen DC lately?
Speaker 1: Dead. Silent. Dead silent.
Speaker 2: We should start with Joe
Biden, and we shouldn't stop there.
Speaker 1: Okay. One person did clap. One
person did clap. This and many other clips we're
going to look at today for me were reminders that
this is Trump's party. This genuinely is Trump's
party. Now, I know Nikki Haley spoke. I know Vivek
Ramaswamy spoke, who's also running for president
against Trump. But this was a Trump crowd. This
was a MAGA crowd. They loved Steve Bannon. They
loved Bo Baer and Marjorie Taylor GREENE and the
entire thing. Kari Lake, they cheered for all
of the election lies and the entire thing. And
this is, quite frankly, Trump's nomination to
lose. This is a line that's done okay in some
of the early primary states when Nikki goes by
herself and it's a Nikki friendly crowd. But
CPAC is Trumpy. Trump is 76, and they recognize
that to some degree, what Nikki Haley is saying
would apply to Trump and they don't like it. So a
hilarious and humiliating moment for Nikki Haley